ghost mi chiamo valentina e sono
fidanzata con oronzo da quasi 11 anni ed
è stato il mio primo e unico fidanzato
da quando sono bambino ho sempre sognato
un matrimonio una famiglia e dei figli
e tu invece voglio aspettare ancora un
altro po perché sto troppo bene a casa
ma durante il nostro rapporto ha
scoperto che ora non so ha sbagliato ho
scoperto numerosi tradimenti e
nonostante questo l'ho sempre perdonato
perché io lo amo io ho un grande difetto
che mi piacciono tantissimo le gonne il
mio punto debole in cosa che non riesco
a resistere
questa esperienza mi servirà a capire se
oronzo guarirà mai da questa famosa
malattia delle donne che dice di avere
solo al cento per cento che sbagli e rho
pero tanto so che lei mi perdoneranno
non temo nessuno dei singoli perché
purtroppo bello è che non mi fanno paura
anticipa lei drastico sia io sono bello
così valentino
[Musica]
o un video per te neanche con me fa così
al mare nonché con me gioca così non ho
ancora trovato la donna della mia vita
dopo dieci anni che stiamo insieme ma
siamo al terzo anno che schifo che mi fa
ma devo ancora trovare ma stiamo
scherzando il mondo vi ho perdonato il
mondo vini oronzo o un video per tempo
[Musica]
filippo solo una cosa voglio dire o
inizia a giocare bene no
torno essere loro non so di sei anni fa
o il diverto perché per adesso mi sono
trattenuto ho fatto il bravo modi vento
brutto perché avevamo troppo ricche in
questi giorni ho capito che mi manca sai
ma in dieci anni ma in dieci anni mila
successe di pensare questa cosa queste
cose piccole sorvolato ti amo l'evento
pensavo ma amati ma la dott.sa buonasera
ciao
niente mi devi dire
tu mi hai fatto venire a cono in dieci
anni ho mai visto quelle cose mai cosa
mi sta succedendo cosa ti sta succedendo
perché tu tu non hai fatto niente per
ora no 0
quindi hai fatto per vendetta questa
cosa uscire con quella persona e farmi
soffrire che sai che poi io soffro la
scelta era un attimo quello che ho fatto
io ti sto chiedendo lo sai che cosa mai
fatta passare da 10 anni a quante cose
ti ho perdonato
lo sai qual è il problema ah ho capito
che ti amo follemente a tu però lo sai
quello che ho visto io quello che hai
fatto quello che hai detto
soprattutto quello che hai detto ti ho
sempre detto che quello che vedi non è
non è come sembra a quello che vedo non
è come sembra a che hanno detto di dire
così
no però non c'è un discorso dietro tutto
un discorso di vetro in vita sono
arrivato qui ho detto vanta fico c'è un
discorso di droga e queste due vite e
centra due vivere il senso che lo sai io
ho due vita è una con te che stiamo
sempre insieme e poi c'è invece la vita
quella che non è che per forza contratto
nè quella mia vita un po spericolata una
vita che è la vita una lo sa tua vita io
devo farne parte problema è che in dieci
anni di vita mai ho pensato che avevo
fatto delle minchiate
mai ho pensato a quanto mi manca
valentina
è tanto dice poi li aspetta a casa ha
detto così era già lo so ma prima
aggiornavo così a perché sei cambiata si
è l'occhio lina perché euro perché delle
opzioni io fiorino avvenuto un picco lo
sa e lo sai che c'è questa malattia
delle donne dopo dieci anni di c che non
ha ancora trovato la donna della tua
vita però ma normale 6 a differenza tua
io era uno scherzo per farti capire come
mi sento tutte le volte che mi hai fatto
soffrire e ii iii questa cosa mi ha
fatto bene
secondo te conoscendo via sarei uscita
subito con un ragazzo conoscendomi mi
sei mancato tantissimo io ho proprio
capito che volevo avere vicino a è no
caro mi ha troppo tardi perché tu ti
vuoi divertire è quella vera ma non
esiste proprio valentina torni a casa da
sola o con il tuo fidanzato ora un solo
stronzo
da sola
da sola veramente da sola dormi
mi sono stancato però mi sono stancato
di soffrire devo pensare a me stessa non
pensare che non ti amo più però mi sono
stancata da sola a casa torni io ho
pensato invece che volevi tornare a casa
con me ho pensato tu non mi rigiro più
oro
io ho una dignità oro me ne torno a casa
[Musica]
post andarmene